-Ryan, you and I both agree
that people do a lot of things
that they have to stop doing.
-Yeah.
-So, with that in mind, it's
time for "You Have To Stop."
-Yeah.
-♪ Doo-boo-do-bo-do,
you have to stop ♪
-Hey.
You have to stop making plans
with me one month in advance.
I'm gonna say yes
because that does sound fun,
but when the day comes,
you know I'm gonna cancel
with some made-up excuse like,
"I'm not feeling well."
And that's not true.
I'm feeling great.
I just don't want
to leave my house tonight.
You have to stop.
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop whispering,
"That looks good,"
at the movies
after every trailer.
"Oh, that looks good."
We know it looks good.
That's --
That's the job of the trailer,
to make the movie look good.
Even bad movies
have good trailers.
I've been in some of them.
It's not impressive
when a trailer looks good.
They all look good. Stop.
Stop.
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop
checking TikTok real quick
before trying to fall asleep.
Oh, you got in bed
before midnight? Congrats.
Oh, you're checking TikTok
real quick?
Well, now it's 2:00 a.m.,
and you're watching
Ring Doorbell videos
of mailmen being surprised
with a basket of Clif bars.
So just stop. Please.
-Yeah. You have to stop
daylight saving time.
We're not farmers anymore.
The only thing
I've ever successfully grown
was this beautifully,
perfectly manicured beard.
And guess what. My kids don't
know what daylight savings is,
and now they're getting up
at 4:00 a.m.,
and I have to tell them
it's because of farmers.
So now my kids hate farmers.
I mean, you're creating
generations of kids
who hate farmers.
You have to stop!
[ Applause ]
-You have to stop
posting screenshots
with your phone battery on 1%.
I'm not looking
at what you posted.
I'm looking to see that
your phone needs to be charged!
Where are you?! Do you have
access to a phone charger?
Do you need to borrow one?
I'm sending help.
But you need to stop.
[ Applause ]
-And, you know, you have to stop
spending over ten minutes
scrolling for a TV show
or movie to watch.
I mean, if --
if you can't figure it out
after that amount of time,
you're never going to.
Just put on "The Great
British Baking Show"
and call it a night.
That's what it's there for.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have to stop bringing back
the McRib, McDonald's.
It's not that the McRib is bad.
It's that you take it away,
and then you bring it back.
What if you did that
with other items?
"Sorry. No hamburgers
till next April.
This month, it's just fries."
That's no way
to run a restaurant.
So just leave the McRib
and please focus on something
more important like fixing
your ice-cream machines.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, you know,
you have to stop saying
that you're gonna move to Canada
whenever you're mad
at something in the U.S.
As a Canadian,
I'm "sorry," but, no, you can't.
I know we're friendly, but
Canada's not your safe house.
I mean, we barely let Canadians
into Canada anymore.
So please...pick somewhere else.
I hear -- I hear Finland is
really lovely this time of year.
You have to stop.
-This has been
"You Have To Stop."
My thanks to Ryan Reynolds.